i'm going to call this executive session
on wednesday 2 23
to order before we start going through
the bills that are being exact the
chairman's called out of the room for a
few minutes but i thought i would ask
the minority leader to introduce the
substitute representatives that are here
today during this session representative
smith
thank you
mr vice chair
yes i wanted to introduce we have
representative maria perez
substituting for representative moran
and we have representative joyce weston
substituting for representative spang
and i see the chair coming so we'll be
starting momentarily thank you
representative
i apologize for being late but hey
it isn't like it isn't like a
presidential press conference you got to
wait an hour
like to call the
held the executive session of the
resources recreation
and development committee
wednesday
february 23rd
and
call it to order this is
this is an executive session
it is
uh there's no testimony there is
but it is
all
discussion is
uh is
among the committee members unless there
is a question of someone in which case
then
the chair will
will
put those questions
the questions will occur through the
chair
uh
i'd like to start with
house bill
66. and is establishing a commission to
investigate and
analyze the environmental and human
and animal health impacts relating to
cyanobacteria blooms in new hampshire
water bodies miss chairman point of
order
pledge
very good thank you
i'll ask everyone to stand
representative creighton could you lead
us in the pledge
to the flag of the united states of
america and to the republic for which it
stands one nation under god indivisible
with liberty and justice for all
all right
the chair recognizes representative
creighton
for motion
thank you mr chairman move 1066 ought to
pass with the amendment
and do you have an amendment available
uh yes sir i do
and everyone's had it at their table
there's do you want me to speak to them
everyone have uh the copy of the
amendment
we expect uh do i have a second to the
so moved
by
representative
egan
uh
would you like to speak to the amendment
uh yes sir i would
the uh
essentially the testimony that we heard
uh
was was overwhelmingly in favor of
doing something about cyanobacteria
and
what the bill stated was to establish a
commission to look at
what we can do to
mitigate and control cyanobacteria
after talking to several folks
after the testimony
it occurred to us that it might be
better just to direct des to do a plan
and that we would achieve the same
results only
much quicker than it would be to do a
commission
des has agreed to do this plan
and so
what i would propose in this amendment
is that we direct ees to develop a plan
by november of 2023
which is what they state is the the
quickest they could do it
that would
address
controlling and mitigating cyanobacteria
in new hampshire
2022-0505h
let's
would you like to speak to your second
i appreciate the sentiment to act
quickly
on this issue
thank you uh
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
on the uh
on the amendment
representative smith
thank you mr chair um i just wanted to
add that uh des does have a plan
for how to uh who the people they're
gonna you know they have suggested
people they're going to work with to
accomplish what the charge is and i
think that uh this is a good uh solution
to a rather than a long drawn out uh
commission to get the work done a little
more quickly
thank you
i would uh i think uh it might it's
kind of irregular and i'd
uh after just getting saying we
shouldn't
i'm not asking for any testimony i do
recognize i could recognize with the i
will i will recognize the uh
head of the water division is that what
uh good enough title mr pelletier just
to make a statement as to
uh
where
the department stands on on this so
simply
there's been much controversy about this
and i think
it will clear some air
thank you chairman renzel for the record
randy pelletier i'm the director of the
water division at des
and to speak to the amendment that you
just
heard about is uh we support it we
believe that
uh cyanobacteria in the last couple of
years has
grown increasingly in numbers and areas
and lakes
is something that we think would be more
timely to address the issues
with performing a study and
i i think it makes a lot of sense the
commissions have a tendency to
languish for a while and i think we can
get on this
once the bill is signed ultimately
hopefully
we'll be able to put a plan in place to
try and move along a report and what we
believe is necessary to at least manage
and and i want to make it very clear we
won't eradicate cyanobacteria but we
certainly
will look at tools and approaches to
manage
uh the causes of them if we can
so i think it's uh the amendment is
makes a lot of sense thank you very much
with that
is there any other questions
amendment
oh
okay
zero five
zero five h
on the on the amendment
to to adopt the amendment
to the clerk please call the roll
thank you representative harb yes
representative huff
yes
representative goldsmith
representative horgan yes representative
creighton yes
representative dodge yes the clerk votes
yes representative philly
yes
representative mayville yes
representative post yes representative
smith yes representative weston
yes
representative grassi
representative gottling yes
representative cohen
representative connors yes
representative vale yes
representative kelly yes
representative perez
yes
representative egan yes
representative renzulu
yes
passed unanimously
okay on on the motion of
of ought to pass
with amendment
house bill
is there anyone who wish to speak to the
motion as amended
seeing none
well on the motion will the clerk please
call the roll
yes thank you
uh representative harp yes
representative huff
yes representative gould
representative horgan yes representative
creighton yes
representative dodge yes
the clerk votes yes representative
healey yes
representative mayville yes
representative post
yes representative smith yes
representative weston yes
representative grassy
representative gottling yes
representative cohen
representative connors
representative vale yes
representative kelly yes
representative perez
yes
representative egan
yes representative renzolu
yes
passed unanimously
okay
consent
it will be on consent and i'll call the
hearing on uh
house bill
or the executive session house bill 1066
over
thank you
now go to
the next
house bill
chair recognizes representative huff
glory
for a uh motion
thank you mr chairman um i move uh to
uh render this and expedient to
legislate i asked for a second and uh
i'd like to talk to my motion
i'll second that mr chair
this to speak to your motion
thank you mr chair
um
it was during the testimony um
that we discovered a couple of things
about uh
the wake surfing
what's problematic with this bill is
that
on our lakes we have
i believe the number was something to
the effect of a hundred
and seven thousand registered boats
um
they all produce a lot of weight
uh
testimony uh
from
the uh opponents of this bill
said that they uh work hard in the
industry to make sure that they're
educated
as to what what to do what not to do
there was also problematic things on the
idea of enforcement
you would have separate
distances
for different activities and boats
and then finally
the other reason that i think bears some
is that new hampshire according to our
governor
was ranked uh the number one state for
freedom uh by the cato institute so with
all of those things in in this i ask
that you uh move this to be itled thank
you so much
do you wish to speak to your second
briefly thank you mr chairman um i echo
the comments of my fellow representative
and further state that based upon the
testimony we heard during the hearing
and my review of the minnesota report i
support the itl motion thank you
anyone else wish to speak to the on the
motion
representative gottling thank you uh i
would just uh like say i'll be voting
against the itl
and uh i believe that the voices of the
hundreds of people that we heard from
including the groups that we work
closely with such as new hampshire lakes
the
rivers management advisory commission
des and many many other lake and
watershed committees that express their
strong concerns
so uh
i believe that their interests need to
be represented also and
so i will be voting against
the itl
anyone anyone else wish to speak on the
bill representative smith
thank you mr chair um i will be speaking
i mean i will be voting against the itl
motion and what what became evident in
the testimony uh in my mind was that a
lot of people believe that this would
limit wake boats to a
further distance from shore than they
now have which is 150 feet but this bill
only addresses the activity of wake
surfing and wake surfing is pretty easy
to differentiate between other
wake sports such as wake boarding and
tubing which require uh which
are more fun if there's a lot of wake
but
the wake surfing the person is only like
eight ten feet at the most behind the
boat and they usually do not even have a
tow rope
and so this activity is a specific
activity and i don't think it's going to
affect tourism uh
as much as
some people had us believe
and then also i believe that the the
wake and the waves produced by this
activity according to two or three
reports that i've read
not just the saint anthony falls one uh
do say that the
waves produced by wake surfing are
measurably larger than from any other
activity and so therefore we do have the
problems with people's docs being
affected
kids getting knocked down by these large
waves so it would only benefit
people using the lake
as well as people on the shore to
increase the distance the safe passage
distance when engaged in wake surfing
thank you
there anyone else who wishes to speak on
the bill
seeing none will the clerk on the motion
to itl 1071.
well the clerk please call the roll
thank you chair uh representative harb
yes
representative huff yes
representative gould
representative horgan yes
representative creighton yes
representative dodge yes clerk votes yes
representative healy yes representative
mayville yes
representative post yes
representative smith no
representative weston no
representative grassy no
representative gottling no
representative cohen
representative connors
representative vale no
representative kelly no
representative perez
no
representative egan no
chair renzulu
yes
past uh 11
motion passes 11 to 10.
motion passes 11 to 10. consent no
okay
just just joking
uh will there be a minority report
representative gottling
and
representative
huff will do the majority
okay
moving on
well i'll call the
session on house bill or
on 1071 closed
and open this uh session on house bill
relative to approval
for off-highway recreational vehicles
used on class
five and class six roads
and chair recognizes representative
representative harb thank you mr chair i
move ought to pass as amended and i
submit amendment 0775h
all right i have copies
of
to pass around
that way
so we'll need a second
uh
oh we'll
okay we'll need a second to the
i'll second it
seconded by uh representative hari bolia
yeah hopefully well you might want to
speak to this or you buy a little or you
want to wish to defer to me
i'll since it's your amendment mr chair
i'll defer to you on the amendment thank
you thank you
thank you very much just uh on the
amendment just to explain uh what is in
the amendment
uh
at the hearing
we heard
my uh
testimony that uh
uh that it would be nice as this were
in uh this bill which is limited at the
time to class of
four in class five
highways
also include would include
class fours
which are basically
uh town town roads but they're in the
compact area
uh also
there was
concern that
having the
uh the bills
or it was concerned that
the uh
passing
of uh
authorization
would uh which would go go to the
uh town
uh the town legislative body
uh
that the rescission of the of the
decision of the town legislative body
uh didn't didn't wasn't symmetrical
didn't match
so the way this
we've it was rewritten so that
the majority by the majority vote of the
legislative body of a town council or
any legal meeting or after et cetera et
cetera you can
the town may authorize the use of class
five
four five and class six highways
and it goes it later goes on to say
except in case of emergency by vote of
the legislative body of the city or town
at any legal meeting
et cetera et cetera the town may rescind
the
town may resend a previous authorization
and may change the allowable usage of
class 5
class 4 5 and 6
highways by ohrvs so another in other
words
if you if the town approves it it ha it
would it was a question as to whether
the approach whether the rescission
would be the same
and this clears that up
it it is it will be the same
is that clear
seeing no questions uh i'll refer back
to uh representative harp
for to speak on his motion
thank you mr chair i think you covered
all the major points why i support the
amendment and then the passing as
amended i
like the symmetrical uh amendment and
the fact that we're putting it back in
the hands of the legislative body
thank you mr chair
uh let's see
representative harvard bowlia do you
wish to speak on your second
no thank you
does anybody else wish to speak on the
bill
yeah as on how okay seeing none
on house bill
[Music]
uh amend an amendment well
first on the amendment on the amendment
uh which is
zero
seven seven five
on amendment zero seven seven five
anybody when we speak on the amendment
specifically
if not
clerk please call the roll
thank you chair um representative harp
yes
representative huff yes representative
gould
representative horrigan yes
representative creighton yes
representative dodge yes
clerk votes yes representative healey
yes representative mayville yes
representative post yes representative
smith yes representative weston yes
representative grassy
representative gottling yes
representative cohen
representative connors
representative vale yes representative
kelly yes representative perez
yes
representative egan
and representative zula
yes
all right the and the now on the
on the bill as amended so on house bill
1109 amend
amended by
by amendment
anyone wish to speak on the on the bill
represent vegan
thank you mr chair uh i support this
bill because i think it's smart that we
allow local control of ohrv
road usage and the amendment makes this
more important of a bill to me
because it allows towns who might want
to allow ohrp to travel on the road to
then understand and deal with the
repercussions and if they find those
repercussions being damaging to that
town they can then
rescind and i think that's an important
aspect of understanding the ohrv
impact on north especially for us in the
north country
that sometimes it sounds good to have
trout
travelers and tourists utilizing the
roads and then when it becomes a cost or
a safety
or a community issue
towns are in a difficult position on how
to unravel what they've laid out and i
think this bill helps give that
unraveling an opportunity to occur and
that's why i would support it and thank
you thank you anyone else wish to speak
on the bill
if not
clerk please call the roll
representative harb yes
representative huff
yes representative gold
representative horrigan yes
representative creighton
representative dodge yes clerk votes yes
representative healey yes
representative mayville yes
representative post yes
representative smith yes
representative weston yes
representative grassy
gottling
representative cohen
representative connors
representative vale yes
representative kelly
yes
representative perez
representative egan yes
representative zulu
yes
past unanimous
consent
i will write the blurb
okay um
that one's finished move on to house
bill house bill 11
28 the liability for damages
relative to financial liability for
damage caused by ohrv use of class six
roads
and
chair recognizes uh representative gould
for a motion
motion to itl as was the second
the chair will second
representative would you like to speak
to your motion or do you
you may i guess uh there is another bill
to have a commission to study issues
with oh hrvs and that should be able to
deal with these issues
thank you
and i will speak to my second
uh
i am the
sponsor of the bill the prime sponsor
and i
thank
representative gould who's co-sponsor uh
and
representative gottling also as a
co-sponsor
uh
i've made this decision that
after listening to the testimony on this
specific bill on the fac on
class six roads
uh that
it's
roads
the real issue of roads
and
their uses as a very complicated
situation
and this
bill
or this the issue that this bill looks
to address
is
best handled
uh by the commission of the
was 1188 house bill 1188
was created created a commission to
study the the
the
issues concerning
ohrvs and their uses on public roads
especially
so
[Music]
i i feel that it is best handled there
and you can always bring it back if
i'm not satisfied but
this is i think is the best place for it
now would be in that commission
thank you
anyone else wish to speak on the uh on
the bill yes
yes
i just wanted to mention that the court
has recently come down with a decision
in gorham in favor of the homeowners and
against the towns
and saying that damages are due
so
that
representative kelly
thank you mr chair yeah i just i wanted
to add i agree with your
decision or the idea to put this in
front of the commission that we're
hoping to establish i think that
uh there is a
there in most cases there's already a
remedy in place and what the problem
amounts to is a messaging issue people
don't know who to contact they don't
know to reach out to the club if the
club has the the class flyercast
classics wrote as a trail on their map
they will be able to apply for funds
to rectify a number of those issues
so i think that what this amounts to is
a messaging problem or a communication
problem and i'm hoping that the
commission will be best suited to deal
with that
anything anyone else wish to speak
if not
on the mo the motion to
itl will the clerk please call the roll
representative harb yes
representative huff yes
representative gould representative
horrigan yes
representative creighton yes
representative dodge yes clerk votes yes
representative healy yes
representative mayville yes
representative post yes
representative smith
yes
representative weston yes
representative grassy
representative gotling yes
representative cohen
representative connors
representative vale yes
representative kelly yes
representative perez yes
representative egan yes
chair franzia
yes
sure okay
we'll have
it's on consent
uh
next bill is
house bill
uh the chair recognizes uh
representative kelly
excuse me uh representative smith
thank you mr chair um i move itl on
house bill
1292.
do i have do i have a second
have a second representative egan
for a second
representative smith do you wish to
speak on your motion yes thank you mr
chair
um
house bill 1292 which would permit the
use of drones or unmanned aerial
vehicles on the statewide trail system
the most of the testimony we heard on
this bill was addressed uh about was
discussing the use of
drones in state parks which are not even
included on the bill although a small
amount of state trails do go through
state parks
and it seemed to me that
that was kind of a a off a little
off-kilter and if we look at the
statewide trail system
majority of those trails are on private
land
and when people uh give permission to
the state to include their property in
the statewide trail system
they fill out a form
and there is a trail use agreement
between dncr parks and rec
and the home and the land owner
and there are you know some of these are
like the trail use agreement is four
pages long and nowhere in it does it
include drones
and
so every
easement
in the state would have to be where the
people are allowing the um
the ohrv's on their property
would or would allow you know they'd
have to include drones in the agreement
so all of those easement agreements
would have to be done over again
and
we heard testimony in the committee that
if this bill passes we will have no
statewide trail system because
landowners are going to
not want the drones uh taking off from
their properties
one of the complaints we heard about the
problem that why we can't have drones we
did have to do with state parks and it
had to do with the slow
perm how slow the permitting process was
on when you were trying to uh get a
permit
to use a drone to do for commercial
purposes
and that
since state parks are not the exact same
thing as state wide trail system it's it
was total misnomer
so i think that this bill is not ready
for prime time it also includes drones
up to 50 pounds
and most p you know i mean that's a
pretty heavy duty drone that is not your
basic you know buy it at walmart drone
so i think it's uh i think the bill's
not ready for prime time and i would
support itl
i ask that we itl it thank you
thank you mr speak to your second
i would mr chair thank you so much um i
echo the sentiments of representative
smith uh
in the part especially that
this will compromise the statewide trail
system and compromise easements that
homeowners
grant to the state and
in
all recognition of representative huff
the freedoms that landowners have that
would be compromised by their privacy
being impacted by drones on their
personal land so not only would it be a
compromising position
for paperwork and legal to rewrite all
those easements but it would then put
landowners in compromised positions and
therefore
i would support i telling this
there anyone else wish to speak on the
uh on the motion
seeing none
on the motion of itl we'll loop
and expediting to legislate will the
clerk please call the role
yes representative harp yes
representative huff yes
representative gould yes
representative
yes
representative creighton yes
representative dodge yes
the clerk votes yes representative healy
yes representative mayville yes
representative post yes representative
smith yes
representative weston yes representative
grassy
representative gottling yeah
representative cohen representative
connors yes
representative vale yes
representative kelly
yes
representative perez
representative egan yes
representative franzulou yes
yes unanimously passed
consent
incentives
okay
well now we'll
close the hearing on 1292 and
open a hearing uh or open the session or
for house bill
1317 and on the previous one the uh
obviously
representative smith will write the
blurb
okay uh on
do i uh let's see
representative huff for a motion on
house bill 1317.
thank you mr chairman
i move that
house bill 1317
requiring the director of the state
police in consultation with the bureau
of marine patrol to report annually to
the legislature regarding new
developments in electric and
gasoline-powered recreational watercraft
be rendered in expedient to legislate i
asked for a second and uh to speak to my
motion
here a second i'll second that motion
representative post for a second
uh
representative for to speak to your
motion thank you mr chairman um
this bill
will add an unnecessary directive
to
the state police and the marine patrol
both of which are excellent at their
jobs and they are always willing to come
by and let us know anything that's going
on so that we can make informed
decisions
so i just
i feel that this bill is just adding an
extra layer that is just not needed
thank you
representative post do you wish to speak
to your second
yes um i echo the sentiment that um we
believe that uh all the information will
come to us um if we have any questions
and um
we rely on um
them to get
information to us that's accurate and
current thank you
is there anyone wish to speak on the
motion representative gotland thank you
i will be voting against the itl
first of all i think that with the
amount of change over we have in our
committees every two years not just with
members but often with the chairperson
there is sometimes a loss of the
institutional history
and the fact that
the
captain dunleavy was
not
was amenable to doing this for us uh i
think says a lot
and i would say that when when
one of our committee members looked at
me and said well
don't they communicate with us like this
every year and i said no and i pointed
out that the bill that i was sponsoring
on efoils
that did not come
from uh
the
department that came from my
observations and my particular chief of
police
so i feel that
giving us a heads up
could save us
unnecessary bill writing if for instance
there's something already in the works
or if
this is something that's
being carried out some other way and
also i do think that the
marine patrol
has the opportunity to go to a national
conference every year
and uh
therefore is often ahead of us
on what are things that are going to be
emerging
so
so i will vote
against the itl and hope many of you
will join me
so anyone else wishes to speak on the
bill
representative
thank you mr chair i i think there's
never anything wrong with more
transparency in getting a report that
echoes the sentiments of
other representatives of
being aware
i am a new member of this committee
so
i'm unaware of anything that you've done
for the last year and a half and a
report for me to look at would be
helpful and i think having those type of
documents not only lets marine patrol
be able to articulate issues that are
occurring
it would educate representatives it
would
as well
save legislative office of legislative
services extra time if
i were to file a bill that if i had read
a report i wouldn't have filed that bill
so all those things
are important to me
thank you
anyone else what else was that
really quick um thanks i just wanted to
note that um i'm in favor of the report
i like the idea of the report i think it
will be definitely helpful but
but my understanding is that the report
has already been agreed to where
the captain has agreed uh is agreeable
to providing the report um without a law
so
that's why i'm voting itl thanks
anyone else wish to speak on the bill
seeing none
motion of itl
will the clerk please call the roll
thank you representative harb yes
representative huff yes
representative goulds
representative horgan yes
representative creighton yes
representative dodge yes the clerk votes
yes representative healey yes
representative mayville yes
representative post yes
representative smith
um
no um representative weston no
representative grassy no
representative gottling yes
yes what no no wait we want to go to
this
representative gottling votes no
thank you to mr chairman for saving my
bacon
representative cohen yes
representative connors
okay representative vail
no
okay
um representative kelly
yes
representative perez
um representative egan no
and chairman zulu
yes
and just wanted to clarify
representative cohen voted
yes correct
okay all right so that's 11 yays and oh
no i'm sorry 11
14 yays
seven
nays motion passes
will there be a minority
will there be a minority report
and who will that be
right will you be writing i will yeah
okay
and represent representative huffield
writing the
uh
the majority
okay uh
before i start on uh
house bill 438 there is some paperwork
that
is left
by
the
[Music]
by the sponsor and
clarifying
something so
thank you
yes
38 relative to moorings
our chair recognizes representative
smith
for a motion
i make a motion of itl
motion of itl is there a second
second representative kelly seconds
representative smith do you wish to
speak to your motion
uh yes
the what we um thank you mr chair one of
the things we learned in testimony
from the
from
the head of the port authority
was that there is already a
plan in place
where people can
they can
give their mooring up for a season
and
no this has been in
they have a temporary seasonal use of
moorings program which is set up through
rules and no one has ever applied to use
that program or to give up their mooring
for a season
and take advantage of those rules
so and then there is a long wait list
for getting your own mooring and that
you know that is a problem but there is
we have a limited amount of sea coast
and also there are some areas where
there is a long wait and there are other
areas where it is easy to get a mooring
so it just it seems very complicated
there were a lot of liability issues
involved in this bill
and it just seems like it's it's just
not a good bill
and also there is a concern that people
who have homes on the
seacoast
for instance in portsmouth or around
nuka around the island of newcastle who
may have a mooring in front of their
home and they'd like to
lease out their home for a air b use it
as an airbnb and although this bill
would not allow you to charge for a
mooring you could raise the price of
your airbnb if you
had a mooring in front of your house and
that would be a huge benefit which would
really
not be a good thing
for the liability issues as much as
anything else so i would ask people to
support the itl motion
wish to speak to you second
thank you mr chair yeah i just i would
add along with what representative smith
said that that i think that this uh
program would open up uh abuse um and it
would be difficult for the uh for the uh
it would be difficult to enforce the the
no payment rule i think that that would
be
a difficult thing to police um and i
just think that their current program is
working
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
to the motion
represent representative harp
thank you mr chair just very briefly uh
i'm a co-sponsor of this bill with the
prime sponsor and he did
convince me that this is a different
program than the seasonal it's only up
to 30 days so
i'm going to
vote against the itl thank you
anyone else wish to speak
on the bill
representative
in testimony we heard uh and i was
educated um about the lack of um
liability control by the more owner
and when they pass on that access to
their more to someone there's no
follow through by the original more
owner and i get concerned that someone
could
use the mooring
cause damages in the area disappear on
the owner and then now there's going to
be a blame of who is liable
so if if the
substitute more users boat damages other
boats then their their time period is up
and they leave town and no one knows
that damages was caused it's back
it's because it can create problems of
who is at
um you know who is responsible and i
think uh
the other side of the issue on this one
for me is as well how do we know if
no funds do
transfer hands we all know that people
make handshake deals all the time and um
that's
a concern of mine so thank you
anyone else wish to speak on the uh
motions
seeing no one
on the motion of
itl
will the clerk please call the role
representative harb no
representative huff yes
representative gould yeah
representative horgan yes
representative creighton yes
representative dodge yes
clerk votes yes representative healey
yes
representative mayville yes
representative post yes
representative smith
yes
representative
uh weston yes
representative grassy
representative gottling yes
representative cohen
representative connors
representative vale
yes
representative kelly yes
representative perez
yes
representative egan yes
representative zulu
oh no
okay
that is
that's 20.
mr chair i'll write the blurb on this
one uh yes
uh representative kelly
uh on now we'll move to
house bill
32.
chair recognizes representative smith
thank you mr chair um i move
itl
on
uh house bill 1532 permitting a dam to
be constructed on big p porridge pond
in general second
you wish you wished to speak to your
motion thank you mr chair
um we heard a lot of testimony both for
and against this bill during
the public hearing
and
what i was left with thinking is that
there needs to be a lot of uh there has
not been good communication between the
people
who live uh on big p porridge pond and
little p porridge pond and that they
before legislation is introduced to put
something into a statute uh be i believe
it's uh
the people who live in those a on those
pawns need to
try to figure out a non-legislative
solution working with des and the dam
bureau
and perhaps legislation will be needed
but hopefully they will be able to
figure out a solution without
having us be the mediators
thank you
thank you i'll speak to my second
uh
i seconded this motion uh because
specifically the chair called me and
requested
that the
bill uh
be
b-i-t-b-i-t-l
uh he recognized he's
uh that there needed to be more work
done uh by the uh
by the people for whom he had put the
bill in
uh
the
he
i i conveyed to him that
uh we that the
least
personally that
i'm sympathetic to the uh to the issue
involved but yes there needed to be more
work done
on the part of the those requesting it
and
so
uh that's that's why i uh
i seconded the motion and
and i would
support the itl thank you
and with that is there anyone else who
wishes to speak
on this issue
there being none
will the clerk piece call the roll on
the motion of ito
on the motion of itl representative harb
yes
representative yes
representative gold
representative horgan yes
representative creighton yes
representative dodge yes clerk votes yes
representative feely
yes
representative mayville yes
representative post yes
representative smith yes
representative weston yes
representative grassy
representative gottling yes
representative cohen
representative connors
representative vale yes
representative kelly
yes
representative perez yes
representative egan yes
representative zulu
yes unanimously passed
consent
consent consent it is
yeah and
the blurb
representative smith
uh about the blurb oh yeah okay
hopefully it's a short one
and on the last two
uh
on house
the chair opens the uh
executive session on house bill
1555 repealing the permit required for
fires at camp campgrounds
chair recognizes representative
creighton for a motion
and thank you mr chairman uh on house
bill one five five five i
move
uh interim study
interim study uh do i have a second i'll
second that motion second by
representative post uh representative
creighton for to speak on your motion i
would
uh we're listening to testimony on uh
house bill 155 and
uh completely understand the desire to
eliminate rules and regulations required
for
personal fires
one of the arguments was that it was
rarely used and that it was difficult
all right
i for one do it and
it takes less than a minute um to to
sign on and and to get that permit
uh what really swayed me on this though
is that
the um
fire safety folks came in and they all
recommended that we keep the permitting
process from a safety perspective
although new hampshire does have a low
incidence of fires we would like to keep
it that way
and so i think that uh
understanding the desire to eliminate
rules and regulations uh
is compelling but uh i think we should
look at it a little bit further and
study it uh to make sure we do it in a
safe and uh
manner that
complies with the
recommendations of our fire safety
people
representative post you wish to speak to
your second
yes um thank you uh
the ease of use you go on your computer
and and you click a button and within
two minutes you can get it done it's a
very simple process
um however for those folks that
don't have computers they can go to
their local fire chief and get it it's a
very very simple thing and the other
thing that they do is they'll come to
your homes and they'll inspect where you
will
have a fire and
an example for my family we built a nice
big pit
however at the end of the pit was a
great big stump and they told us we
couldn't have the fire there because
that would
could
cause the roots of that
tree that stump to start burning and
could actually go into underground a
fire and go into our neighbor's yard
which was very heavily treed so this is
why i support
the ita or interim study on this bill
thank you
anyone else wish to speak on the bill
representative egan
thank you mr chair um this this bill's
an issue for me and while interim study
is plausible i would have preferred it'd
be itl
i think it's rare that the new hampshire
timber owners association and new
hampshire
site for production of forests are on
the
distinct same side of this issue and
both gave testimony and reinforced with
information that they sent to the
committee talking about how bad of an
idea this bill is
as well i did speak with a constituent
who was a firefighter
in my neighborhood who told me a
unpermitted fire
in dalton drew six towns of fire crews
volunteers risking their own lives put
out a fire because someone didn't get a
permit to start a fire when they could
have been educated by their fire
department their fire chief
and it causes
concern for me that we want to
do away with a smart piece of
legislation that protects our
neighborhoods our forests so while i'll
support an interim study i would
preferred
more
ending of a ridiculous bill that
just doesn't make sense so thank you for
hearing me out
anyone else wish to speak on the motion
seeing no one else on the motion of
interim study will the clerk please call
the role
on the motion of interim study
representative harp yes
representative huff yes
representative gould
representative horgan yes
representative creighton yes
representative dodge yes
the clerk votes yes representative
healey yes
representative mayville yes
representative post yes
representative smith yes
representative weston yes
representative grassy
representative gottling
yes
representative cohen yes
representative connors
representative vale yes
representative kelly yes
representative perez
yes
representative egan yes
representative friend zulu
no
okay let's
uh pass 20 to 1.
he's gotten consent
design consent
river
i have a motion of interim study uh is
there a
second
second by representative smith
representative gottling do you wish to
speak to your motion yes um
there are many people in favor of
extending how much of the merrimack
river is protected
but not in the way that is being done in
this particular bill where they feel
it's bypassing the process that's
already uh
uh
in
so it it seems as if you know we should
be able to uh it perhaps one of the
reasons is that the
process often takes several years
and this may be a shortcut to getting
the
protection that is wanted but i think
interim study may let us figure out a
good way to do it without
totally overwriting the process that's
usually used
representative smith to wish to speak on
your second
yes it has come to the committee's
attention also that department of
environmental services has now sent
letters to the committees of communities
that would be
part of this designation
and uh once we hear back that those
committees
communities are
in favor of this that would be one step
forward and um
on this process but the process has
worked well for a number of years and it
makes sure that everyone involved and
anyone who lives near the river or has a
business near whatever river it is
will have a say and be able to
act responsibly
and
vote to designate their river
with a full array of knowledge so i
think that interim studies a good choice
any anyone else wish to
speak to the motion
representative vail
thank you mr chair
i also support the interim study and i
just wanted to add along with echoing
the comments of my colleagues that i
know that this kind of a project takes
volunteers and it takes stewards in the
community and this would give the time
in order for that process to develop
there are a lot of volunteers involved
with being a steward of the river and
i think this will give us the time thank
you
anyone else to speak on the motion
i think the chair would like to say one
thing
i applaud the
uh initiative of the uh of the
representative
uh but
there it because i think the
the
protection of the rivers are important
uh uh
however there there is a real reason
that for the for this process to be
as
what some would say is slow and
cumbersome
it
you're talking about
about taking uh changing the use or
restricting the use of the of an area of
other of property of land that other
people may own
so everyone should have
their say in it there should be no about
there should be no surprises
and that takes time and it takes effort
but uh so this the process has worked
well
and
i realized that we we could have
uh
do a
notwithstanding type of bill that
goes around the process
but that would be wrong
so i suppose do support the
the effort
so
with that
see no one else wish to speak
on will the on the effort on the motion
to uh interim study
i'd ask
the clerk to call the role
on interim study representative harp yes
representative huff
yes
representative gold
representative horgan yes
representative creighton
yes representative dodge yes
the clerk votes yes representative
healey yes
representative mayville yes
representative post yes
representative smith yes
representative weston yes representative
grassy
representative gottling yes
representative cohen
representative connors
representative vale yes
representative kelly yes
representative perez yes
representative egan yes
representative from zulu
yes
21-0
consent
looks like it yes it was be consent all
right uh
that is and before uh well
i uh
i'm not going to adjourn the executive
session
i'm going to
recess it why because
at one o'clock we have a work session
on 1602
and it is my intent
to
after the work session and after we come
to an agreement on a
on an amendment
to that bill
i would plan to move into executive
session
to take care of that bill my other
choice would be we come back next week
for one bill how's that yeah i don't
think i i i think this is the better
choice
so uh
uh
as i uh as i will recess this uh
uh executive session uh to uh after to
to the uh until the afternoon
uh uh representative uh huff do you have
a just just a question when will you
require the uh the blurbs
uh the blurbs
uh
if i'll try to
if you can get them to me by saturday
that'd be good
thank you
any more questions any questions on
where we're gonna where we're going this
afternoon
right
where
we're we're
at one o'clock at one o'clock we're
we're meeting right here so
we will do our work session
uh yes that will be representative
representative glattling you are doing
the blurb on the last bill right
okay uh i am not going to jared i am
going to recess the executive session
until this afternoon
all right
i got time oh i'm still
that is always the toughest part yeah
i know
i know that was tough because
now
okay
it's gonna be longer than five minutes
let me see if i can move it back a
little bit so at least i could be a part
of it
no it's because if for some reason i can
run out and it's time to vote i'll just
tell my friend
he'll say you gotta hold on i gotta go
home yeah well i mean that's true
especially if you're just gonna be in
the hall
right
yeah and you have to be here when the
question is called
so
yes
is
um
kids
now
uh
thank you
i have to vote
uh
thanks
okay all right thanks
bye
they were shocked
she was just walking
um
well uh
is
uh
turn off your mic
you
gotta turn this on first
i guess i gotta start now i'm gonna
start over it's on uh house bill 1602
relative to perfluorinated chemicals in
drinking water
uh an executive session
on pending legislation may be held
throughout the day time permitting well
in this case we will make use of that
that after
uh after we dispense of
this
uh with this work session
uh
the issue was and uh correct me if i'm
wrong uh
raise your hand this is an issue
it was concerning the uh
the
requirement that
people uh that the um
small business owners the owners of the
uh
of these
daycare centers and
schools etc
would have to
pay for
testing
for
perform you know pfas chemicals
at certain times
and
we are concerned about
who pays and why
uh
does anybody want to
talk about that or well i'll recognize
or
you have a proposal as
the only thing i'd like to know mr
chairman are we dealing with the bill as
amended did we vote on the amendment at
the last time we met
good question
so i think we did i know the moment the
amendment was placed but i don't know if
we if we did vote i thought we had but
i'm i'm not sure
yeah it would be
well it was this one this was an
executive
what i would suggest then sir is that we
basically move to amend the bill
at this time and i'll move the the
amendment uh well i guess this is
workshop what i would do is is to move
to have it amended by the amendment that
we have in place which is uh
oh five eight five
um
and that that's that be what we work
with as far as the bill is concerned
all right well let's look at 0.585
representative smith do you have a
question yeah does that
does the amendment uh representative
grassy replace the entire bill yeah yes
it does well
it's sorted by section one
i don't think it replaced that doesn't
it's we're talking about amendment 0.585
yeah it re it replaces the bill and it
adds a section 3 in it which uh
basically exempts uh schools which are
uh
or talks about the testing should be
done at sources and exempt schools that
are on public water supplies
you're right
it does well it's it's not quite it says
because there is a
is
well you have this you have a section
one where it says pfast level of
drinking water schools and child care
facilities amend
485 by inserting after second 17a the
following new subsection
and then it says
colon 17b
and that that's where the the uh
where the amendment starts so there is
us
a there is a two sec two some of the
line sentence
in the beginning correct
well yeah there is basically the the
introduction
section the new new sections it talks
about pfs level drinking water schools
and child care facilities and also for
per and fluorocarbon substance levels
and drinking water in schools and
licensed child care facilities but
that's right here that's what it's not
so basically it just takes it's the one
section it says one new section right
that's the only one line that it keeps
and the rest of it changes yeah so
so you know in effect it really does uh
replaces the whole place pretty much
with the exception of the two
introductory sentences
but as i think we can discuss
we can discuss right off of the
amendment and uh
we'll just maybe we'll just be working
with the amen whether we amend the
amendment
if i i will speak mr chairman and i
think that one of the things that it
does here and there was a concern that
people had
about the funding of the of the bill and
that uh des said that they had funding
available currently
uh that they would go out and complete
these uh schools and child care centers
that had not been tested uh some of them
haven't us but these are the ones that
wouldn't be tested they would take it
out of existing funding
and a concern i have is if we ought to
address any additional funding would
that create a situation where we would
have a fiscal note and then we can't
send it to a second committee it's too
late to send to the second committee at
this time so basically it would die
and i think that if we want to or if
there is a need
if des feels that there is a need to
provide any additional funding that that
could be addressed in the senate
because that's the only place we can go
really to add any additional funding in
this bill
smith for comment yes thank you mr chair
um
brandon kernan from des is here and
he has a um he has a handout that he'd
like to share with members
about the um
that would help with the question of
who's going to test how is it going to
get test and what it's going to cost
yeah i mean this is a work session so
it's
yeah you can you can participate
thank you chairman i'm brandon kernan
i'm the administrator of the drinking
water and groundwater bureau
and i testified originally on house bill
i have not seen a copy of this uh
a proposed amendment
but in thinking about today and i
apologize for getting this too late it's
been incredibly busy for all of us
we we wanted to provide some background
and maybe some incremental steps that we
can take
before maybe we pass
legislation that
imposes requirements both on these
entities and also des relative to
administering it
um
one thing i just want to explain is that
department of environmental services
regulates public water systems when we
start talking about
having requirements for child care
facilities and schools
you're kind of expanding the entities
that we have to work with from 2600
water systems to another 1500 entities
that we don't even have in our databases
yet or anything so it's
it's a big lift and it's a lot of work
and you have to think about the process
that would
that goes into place where
we have to tell people the sample they
have to collect the data that's
submitted to us we have to chase it we
have to analyze it respond to it require
mitigation require testing after
mitigation requirement notification
verify public notification for 1500
entities
potentially at like 300 different
sampling taps in our testimony letter we
explained some changes to the bill that
would improve it and it sounds like this
amendment might address it you know
sampling just sources see i'm not
sampling facilities that are connected
to a public water supply
that already are sampling for pfas at
the source swells
and then that des could use money
dedicated to pfas that we have in hand
over the next year i said 18 months
originally but we could do it over the
next year to offer to sample those 1500
child care facilities and public schools
that aren't a public water system they
essentially have a private well just
like a homeowner has a private oil
because they're small enough that they
don't enter our regulatory
spectrum
and so what we propose here is that we
do that sampling over next year and i
have to say it would be voluntary on the
on the facilities part uh we have no
authority to mandate they allow us on
site and some will not they don't want
to do with extra regulation or
regulators
many will let us on
and that we do two things
one in the next couple months we provide
this committee an interim report
right now we have
data for all the public water systems
that had sample for pfas it's about 1200
systems 1600 sources and what we can do
is match the 1500 child care facilities
and schools with the water systems
over the next couple months and then
give you the pfas data for each
child care facility in school so we
essentially have the data we have to
match it up at this point because we
have
water system data and we need to connect
it to the buildings that we have on a
separate list
and so within a couple months we can
give you that information which is
about thirteen hundred fifty results out
of fifteen hundred total of the
empties we're talking about
and so you can look at the data and see
to what extent there's a a need to do
more to require extra public
notification or parent notification or
what have you
and then over the next year collect that
additional data for the facilities that
led us and then pull that back into the
data summary and so within a year you'll
have a full picture of what the exposure
to pfas phases and these facilities and
based on that decide should we require
three rounds of sampling over the next
15 years should we require extra public
notification beyond what the public
water system already does
but it would give useful information to
make really good decisions within a year
and we wouldn't be asking for any
additional funds from the legislature to
do that
uh yes just a question you said that
that you had no authority to go in and
do the testing
under this uh this bill it says that
these facilities shall test so it may
not be you that test them but they would
be required to be tested um under
standards which you shall set and they
would be submitting that information
into you so this would remove that
problem that you're saying that well
there may be some places that we aren't
able to test and this is true that all
the tests gets all the facilities get
tested and according to your records
alone there are only about
uh 150 schools and child care centers
that currently are not
have not submitted data
right i'm talking about our different
approach so yes if we went with your
approach and the amendment
they would be would have to but that's
where there's a lot of resources
required because
we'd have to produce sampling schedules
for these facilities they would have to
contract or contracted labs get results
feed into a database that doesn't exist
for these facilities because we don't
have these in our
in our system right now
and then based on it we'd be issuing
violation letters and making them have
corrective action plans to mitigate an
exceedance and then they'd have to prove
they do that and then we'd also have to
administer
a notice that they have to do public
notification and then they'd have to
prove it to us and again we all have to
log that in database it's a big process
it's like 11 points of contacts with
these entities that we don't even work
with right now you know they're used to
either healthy services if you're a
child care facilities or department of
education if you're a school and also
you're going to have another regulator
and ultimately in des i think most you
know really tries to hold out as long as
we can before we get to that ultimately
we'll be finding him you know so now
we'd be finding very small daycares
which which is not
you what we really want to think about
before
we get into that business so
what i was proposing is just a solid
approach to get information
to the extent someone has a result over
a standard
almost any facility would take care of
it and if they didn't have five thousand
dollars to put a treatment system in or
a thousand if you just do one sink they
get a bubbler or provide bottled water
and put up a sign you know so
i think this approach really would
identify
any remaining exposure and give us the
means to eliminate it
in a cooperative way and there could be
a weird issue out there you i mean
there's always an exception but that's
not often you run across those types
just just to clarify you said this
approach
is that the amendment approach
or a separate approach oh i'm sorry it's
the handout that i prepared just sort of
uh which is different than the amendment
yes i haven't seen the amendment
okay
yep
and it's a bit it's a
big improvement in our view from the
original bill we're just trying to think
of even a more streamlined approach to
address this concern
and it doesn't give up on the idea of
doing more
regulatory wise it just gives you i mean
right now the committee doesn't have the
full picture of if this is a real
problem or not and what measures
therefore should be taken so within
two months you would have
basically 80 of the answers and then
within a year you'll have as completed
with pictures we have except for those
facilities that don't let us sample
and then we can say well gee you know we
have 10 percent exceedance this many
kids
yeah we need to make sure we have this
much sampling and then we have to have
this additional notification beyond what
the public water systems do already it's
just a thought and it's something that
we can do with existing data and
resources in funds for a following sir
okay
do you need legislation to do that or
are you fully authorized to do that now
we can i can commit to that we'll do
this now we are we're able to do this
you could put it into legislation to
require it legally but i think we work
with each other all the time we can
commit to getting the data to you in two
months that we have and then
sampling wherever we can get access to
within a year and i have the
commissioners buy into that
thank you very much that's very helpful
thank you
if we put this bill or this amendment
into legislation
will this make you make protection of
young children's drinking water in these
schools from pfaster prioritization when
you look at what you're doing next year
does it give it extra as opposed to
we'll we'll get to it we'll tell you
we're going to do it
if it's if it's a law if it's as the
amendment says
it's something you must put a high on
your priority list next year is that
correct or not correct
if we would work within the deadline we
have
i mean
there are so many quote unquote
emergencies revolving pfs right now we
have thousands of wells that are
exceeded exceeding we have a backlog of
hundreds of wells to sample the harder
we work the more work we have we'll get
this done within the time frame we
commit the way we would do it is
integrated with our other initiatives so
if you have a daycare in center harbor
while we're sampling contaminated homes
in center harbor we do the daycare so
we would work it in with all the other
very important priorities and just make
it efficient as possible
we'd integrate the work and that's what
we do now
follow on please follow us so um
again the question was if we if this
becomes law
you have to make it a priority do you
have to make it a priority as opposed to
working it with testing other houses in
wolfeboro or whatever
it
it would make it the same level priority
because we have an obligation legally to
address those contaminated wells in
other communities so the priorities are
equal identifying and eliminating
exposure
okay thank you for the information
what else for a question or a
comment
i'm just looking at
the amendment itself
it's it says that the school or licensed
child care facility shall as an interim
measure ensure that the children are
provided only drinking water that meets
the standard and it goes on to say that
the school of licensed child care
facilities shall also
implement a remediation plan as approved
by the department within 30 days of
notification of parents
or in contra consultation with the
department as soon as practically
it was practical
yeah all right uh
the my concern is that
uh
you said well they can just give the
kids
drink and you know give the kids bottled
water
that's
that's not what the bill says the bill
says it's got to be you know
i would i would love to see it say
in lieu of this
in lieu of all of these changes if you
supply the kid's bottled water then
you're covered
and
even though it's a an interim that could
uh at least as an interim and
probably as a
as
a uh
as a as a
complete
perma as a permanent uh solution
kids drink
water and buy the bottled water
but i'm not certain that this bill does
this that's my biggest concern and i
don't want to have this
uh steamroll into a larger into a costly
uh item that it really doesn't have to
be
yeah you know mr chairman i mean
certainly bottled water for the children
is fine but they're not using bottled
water to wash their hands if the
facilities cooking meals they're
probably not using bottled water to cook
some of the meals and that's where you
get into the problem is that if there's
pfas in the water
it talks about a remediation plan that
needs to be put in place and they need
to start working on getting it up it
doesn't say they have to do it overnight
but it also says we're practical so they
would be working with the department to
come up with some sort of plan
that they can put into place in a
reasonable amount of time to eliminate
pfas or get it below the standards that
are required um you know just saying
we're gonna have bottled water and
expect that they're gonna use bottled
water to wash their hands that they're
going to use bottled water to cook their
food that's
kind of unreasonable and i don't think
that that's something that some
facilities would do i mean one of the
reasons why this bill got put in is
because there is a
lack of
of
basically compliance to make sure that
all our children are in facilities
particularly licensed facilities i mean
if we license them we're saying to the
people who bring their kids there that
these are places that the state of new
hampshire feel are safe for their
children to be at
and the thing is is that we haven't been
making sure that they're all safe
because we don't know what the situation
is with with pfas i mean you you take a
look at the reporting things about
schools that are even the state website
isn't up to date
on some of the information on schools
that are that have pfas in the water in
schools they don't have pfas or art
schools that have lead in their water
and don't have light in the water i mean
we need to get this information up to
date and maybe this bill goes a step
further than some people feel
comfortable with because it requires
that we provide a situation where our
children are safe when you bring your
child to a daycare center and it's they
have a license hanging in their wall or
a school that says that they are
certified by the state of new hampshire
they should meet the standards of the
state of new hampshire and this is one
way to do it this is one way to ensure
compliance
so out of the roughly 1500 entities we
know the water meets standards or is on
a path to meet standards for our mcl for
p fest for 1 350 out of the 1500 in
round numbers so that remain gives you
the remaining fifth 150 private wells
which we propose to address
using the
approach here um
a lot of these facilities probably don't
cook but if they do that could be could
be a concern washing hands dermal
exposure isn't considered a risk right
now we don't recommend people use
bottled water for washing
washing your hands i will say those 150
entities that we have no data for it's
because they're akin to a private well
they're essentially like a household
except they're watching kids and
unfortunately
until we have appropriate resources from
the responsible party which might take
litigation and sample every well in the
state
our kids all over new hampshire probably
exposed to pfas right now because half
the state's on a private well for which
we
are trying to sample hot spot areas but
you need to sample every well for pfas
in the state to know if you're exposed
or not because it can exist anywhere
there are
the camps are now with hhs i got moved a
few years ago
there are some requirements i know it's
definitely like
nitrate nitrite and bacteria
for for the facilities and i'd have to
see what other parameters are required
but that's part of
the licensing for the child care
facilities hhs obtains that information
i would prefer
hhs to answer that it seems like it's an
approach um it is a costly test
if you don't know enough and just call a
couple places someone might charge you
500 to sample for it if you know how to
do it
most efficiently it could be two hundred
dollars so for these very small
businesses is a
cost up also
okay all right so
uh i don't know if this is necessarily a
question for you i'm just throwing this
out there but you said
you just said that you know it could be
a 500 cost or it could be whatever so
i'm assuming that that means that the
state does not pick up the tab for this
under
well if
that legislation went through
the way it's worded is that the facility
has to collect the sample des probably
could go sample it
at least for the next year our funds
won't be available after 18 months and
so for the next two rounds after the
first round and if that's still in the
amendment three rounds of sampling the
facility would have to pay the cost
right and then and then follow up on
i'm not so much uh concerned about the
idea of of the getting of the sample i'm
more concerned about um
as i've lost my thing here about
the uh unfunded mandate
where they would have to come up with
remediation
um
theoretically what that would mean is is
if they get it tested whoever does the
testing then the next step would be if
they was to be found then this this
entity whether it's a a public school or
a private business is now going to be
hit with with the money to to do the
remediation to whatever that is and 28 a
of our constitution says no unfunded
mandates so
i'm just saying that if i'm reading that
right
that's a problem
well the
as far as a question uh
a law is not a 28
it's i think the 28a issue is
whether something goes from this
state mandating something to the towns
i'm not mistaken
well your towns are in control of your
schools
that
that is that could very well be that
that is possible i'm just yeah i
need clarification
i hadn't looked at that
suzanne did you have a question
thanks for being here mr karen
um
in the
the um
the
let me move this okay the amendment um
talks about remediation
and is there funding available state
funding available for pfas remediation
if it was d i mean what would be the
next step after you found pfas in the
drinking water at one of the schools
that
was on a private well
presently
so right now if we found
pfas and private well with no viable
responsible party
we may provide bottled water temporarily
although
because we have thousands of private
wells that are contaminated that's
something less of an option
i'm just even finding someone to buy the
deliveries of bottled water
it may be that the facility has to go
ahead and expend its own funds put
treatment on we do have a small grant
program to help school and child care
facilities with the design cost of
treatment which is about 26 percent of
the cost which could be
these small systems would probably be
like about 5 000
so
but that's based on the availability of
funding and the pfas funding is being
utilized pretty swiftly so i'm not sure
as you get out in the second and third
rounds of sampling that funding would be
available
a few years from now or 15 years from
now
follow-up
yeah so in in your proposal which would
eliminate the need for
legislation at this point in time
um
and if des was finding pfas in the in
the in the testing of those wells is
there any then what would happen
the entity would be notified that they
are being exposed to unsafe levels and
provided
education on how to deal with that
bottled water
probably for the short term
and some people especially smaller
facilities could use it for cooking
point of use treatment which would be a
little filter and a separate tap on the
sink which
would only be for drink potable water
uses it could be used for
cooking and it's 200 if you do it
yourself a thousand dollars if you pay
someone to do it or a whole facility
treatment system which is about five
thousand dollars to treat every drop of
water that's going into the building
and again
we could fund about 26 of the costs
until the funds are not available
anymore
until the funds are not available anyway
okay so it's a similar process once the
pfas is detected and whether the
legislation happens or it doesn't happen
well we would have no
authority to force a private entity
that's not a public water system to
implement corrective action we would
work really hard with these people just
to educate them and make them aware of
the availability of grants but we
couldn't
require that they mitigate the water
quality as proposed in the bill
okay thank you
you had just said a minute ago
on remediation
that they could put a small thing on
their faucet or they could put a large
system in there were options here are
you saying that if you have pfas
in your water there's something you can
put on your faucet right now
to
pull out the pfas from your water that
comes out of your faucet
so
it's called point of use and it's a
technical term but it means you're
treating water at a certain location
only and that way it's a lot more
efficient than treating things going
through your sinks and showers and
all that
or not sinks out toilets and showers and
so yes there you can put a carbon filter
that essentially screws into the
incoming water line and then into your
cold water and it'll treat all the water
coming out of your kitchen faucet that'd
be a carbon filter only remove pfas
another option is to put up you have
some people like those little soap pumps
next to the faucet you could drill a
hole in your sink or displace that soap
pump
and put a second faucet that that has
its own tap and that's being treated
with reverse osmosis which takes not
only pfas out but the arsenic and
uranium and nitrates and everything else
that you're worried about and that's
very cost effective you buy them 200 at
the big box stores and professionals
will put them in for about a thousand
follow on please
so i'm just following your logic here
i'm very familiar with the case of pfas
contamination in this town of merrimack
so that's why i'm using it as an example
why didn't the department give every
resident that needed that
that device as opposed to saint gerbain
had to pay for bottled water for all
those residents it seems like that would
have been a simpler solution is there a
reason why that didn't happen that way
if it takes the pfas out
so i was pretty involved with saint
gobain and
merrimack private wells and public wells
up to a couple years ago so i can tell
you what i know but i haven't been
involved recently
so initially and there's whole work
plans on this um that cinco bain did in
fact put in point of entry and point of
use
systems in some of the initial homes
that were contaminated
the problem is
it got so big so fast the number of
wells that were contaminated all the
while the water line extension started
occurring and being designed and so it
became more logical to stop putting in
these filters when you were extending
water lines because it was going to
happen soon enough and so it just made
sense to proceed that way to put the
resources towards
expediting the water line extension but
again i haven't been that involved
recently so okay thank you for the
answer
thank you for taking the question so
my question is regarding public record
and transparency with your data sources
if you're testing these 150 schools
child care center wells where does that
information go is it a matter of public
record can a parent go on to your
website and say our school is at blah
blah or is that is that not because to
me that kind of peer pressure also helps
in
in encouraging people
to remediate because i'm certainly not
going to take my child to a school that
has pfas levels that are through the
roof if they're not remediating so is it
a matter of public record i guess
yes the data is ultimately available to
the public you know we have data for
about 9 000 private wells and we choose
not to make a table and put it online we
have a viewer where you can look at an
app and look at results but you can't
get in close enough to get the exact
location but ultimately if someone asks
for data that we collected and have in
our systems we have to give it so if
they said i would need it for 10 smith
street we would give that to them now
these are businesses and this is a
legislative initiative i could see a
scenario where we'd be comfortable with
publishing a table of private well
results
for child cares in schools private or
public we already do that for public
wells we submit a report twice a year to
the legislature summarizing the pfast
results
and so those entities those schools and
child care facilities that are regulated
public water system and there's a couple
hundred of them that data's online and
available and submitted to the
legislature
and you can submit a data request where
we would just print it all out an excel
spreadsheet for you as well for any
given water system or town or whatever
constraints you wanted to put around a
data request
so just in terms of expediency and i'm
just thinking because i'm a resident
mayor mack
how fast we can get this information
it's from what you're saying it's faster
if you we
kind of move with your plan versus going
through the legislator and going to the
senate and then wait for the governor to
pass it or not and then
agreeing that you'll move that forward
there's some pieces in the legislation
that
protect the public
probably a little more expansively
but the testing is really what i'm
interested in because
these people have got to stop being
exposed to this stuff so do you agree
that this is a faster way to do it
i do um so what you give up is the
enhanced public notification so like
when merrimack had accedences they had
to notify the public and probably most
of the people i went to merrimack
schools
were on mvd water but not everyone but
then what merrimack village district is
required to do per state requirements is
they're encouraged to notify the parents
of the water quality issue but we don't
enforce that we don't have a rate and
that'd be a nightmare if we had to start
tracking down
three levels of notification to
customers of water systems so you'd be
giving that up and also the requirement
to mitigate if you were a private
childcare facility but you're right you
would get the full picture
and then you could act
after you have all the data to see if
you thought you needed legislation if
you get if we come back to you and say
they won't let a sample they won't fix
though pfast problem they said it's they
don't believe the science you know then
you would know that maybe more
regulations
uh required at that point i will i did
want to point out and it's a little off
topic but it's all going to get tangled
together ultimately this bill is kind of
modeled off the lead in school
legislation and there's a house bill
1421 and senate bill 452 that are all
increasing testing and notification
requirements and mitigation requirements
responsibilities ds
when you put these things together it's
going to get really complicated too and
so and costly i mean we can't absorb it
we need all
the way we do what i said before tell
people a sample get the data react to
the data mitigate the water track that
get another sample and then track future
sampling and track public notification
is all through databases you cannot do
that manually especially at 1500
entities
and
and so
it's just gonna it's gonna it's creating
a whole new regulatory program at des
ultimately and i'm not
i'm just trying to tell you how it is we
won't be done well if we don't staff it
the way we staff our drinking water
program because you just don't do this
one by one the data flows in
electronically and flows out
and people get mad at our letters
because often the computer's behind the
letter based on a logarithm you know so
it's just the way you have to do things
these days
thank you mr chairman i think he
answered my question though based on
when he answered the last question
because the concern i had was the
notification of parents
in the bill it requires that the parents
be notified of the positive tests within
five days you're saying that if you find
a positive test you'll tell the facility
but there is no requirement for anybody
to notify the parents
that's correct uh i mean i think a
school system and a school board would
be pretty unhappy with administration if
they did not
follow that advice and warn about water
quality and there's a
political process to make sure you have
the right people representing the school
system to see those things through but
ultimately someone could make that
decision that no i'm not going to tell
them you just just just follow up um you
know it doesn't understand there are
only 150 of these schools and it's so
it's probably not a lot of public
schools but there are larger daycares uh
preschools that are out there private
facilities more than anything else that
you're dealing with i know of a private
facility up in wakefield it's got 50
kids in it
um and and it's on a well and i don't
know if they've tested their water or
not they would i would hope they had
more than 25 people six months of the
year has to be uh non-transient so it's
the smaller ones that a parent who may
have not have a lot of options for child
care
is finds out you know that they get
tested the facility is tested positive
and the parent may not know
and if they did know they may be able to
make another choice but if they don't
know when nobody wants to tell them
because the person's saying god if i
tell my parents they're all going to
leave me and i'm going to be broke what
do i do and i won't tell my parents
that's
this bill would require that that be
done and somebody would verify that had
been done
thank you i just um wanted to ask mr
kernan
um i see that um new hampshire des has a
great gis website with a lot of sampling
data for the whole state
um which is available on the on the
website easily found
through a google search and
it's broken down into three different
categories like
um
below 70 parts per trillion and
could you could you speak a little bit
about that are parents using this i mean
i assume that if
in the higher uh the communities that
have more hits
at this website i mean should be a great
resource for them thank you yes um
people are using it
it alleviated a lot of requests for
information about pfast by just putting
it all out there and
that website feeds directly from our
databases so as the lab reports data for
private or public wells into our
database and they do it electronically
that once a week refreshes that map
the thing we've done on that map we have
an internal version that shows you
everything right down to the
the name of the person and the address
but the external version
blocks that out and if you try to zoom
into an actual home it'll gray out but
you can certainly at a neighborhood
level see results and if you only have
one building
out in a rural area you'll be able to
figure out whose result it was pretty
easily just one step it's trying to give
people information they can follow up
and request for the specific data for a
specific neighborhood but just not
trying to put too much personal
information out there unless people
really need to take that extra effort to
find it for a very specific reason
representative
okay that being from merrimack
i the one thing i do want to add is
you can also exempt the schools that
have put already put filtration systems
in merrimack every school has been done
cost of six million dollars it was the
taxpayers that got hit with that bill
so that's what i'm saying when you're
dealing with these things the the 70 per
trillion is the epa
minimum
new hampshire's now is 12 to 18
depending on what it is
so
on when any whenever you're dealing with
these schools like this though you
you've got to realize that
when we
when they brought that you brought that
to the town the town made the decision
to do to filter schools
we weren't going to get any money and so
the thing that they're you know the
schools are looking for now is how do we
get recourse in the long run so that's
and hopefully so that's going to eat a
little bit more money if that ends up
happening too so that's another thing
i'm still full full of fog here i mean
what do we do
do we move forward with the bill or you
have here a
a proposal in lieu of the bill
that would give you
a data summary in a year
to see
what that nature of the problem is and
the proper remedy for it okay
and
we're trying to shake out i test what
the bill gives
and what
this gives and
is is
you know the bill is stronger but it has
a lot of
stronger things in it
that
some of us might find
not palatable your
your uh
correct me if i'm wrong this is just my
what i'm seeing
but your
your sis
is
more palatable because
but it's not intrusive
and you're paying for it right it won't
have to go to fiscal or finance what
does it the question is does it give
what is it
what do we end up with
once it's over and do we then
uh is
is it you know is it one or the other or
both
so
where where are we going on this
um
i'll tell you where i'm going but i
won't tell you i won't tell you where
i'm going because i don't want to weigh
the you know this
this is
one
i'm well one person among 20 i'm 21. so
go ahead
had another thought
you said there's 150 schools in child
care facilities and i always think of
schools as being under public control
under the town control and child care
facilities as being private is there is
there differentiation between how many
of those 150 are actually schools and
how many are child care facilities
i believe it's about a 50 schools and
there's a lot of privately owned for our
non-profit schools that the towns aren't
associated with say it again
i said there's a
there's about 50 small either non-profit
or for-profit small schools that don't
have a municipal association
representative perez and representative
post thank you
um my only concern
and i'm i'm here helping with the
committee but i i do have a little bit
of concern like um
will you proposal the school
up not gonna be um forced to
let the parents know
yeah you can talk to the schools but
you're not
it's not going to be a lot that is going
to force the school
to provide that to the parents
and then to be honest for what i'm
seeing in my town we we we've been
having a lot of issues with water
contamination we get keep getting brown
water like
almost black water
and they keep telling us keep let the
water run let the water run
we don't know how many of these
children's in our town because you know
some parents that work all the time they
drink in that contaminated water so
i'm a little concerned that's the only
thing that i'm a little concerned they
have you know if with your proposal that
it's not going to be a way yes you can
talk to them but it's not going to be
enforcement for them to
send the report to the parents and then
with all that you know the issues that
we have with water contamination i'm a
little concerned you know we got to
think about the future of our kids you
know the next generation
and uh
you know this can cause
you know other issues
um so that's that's my only concern
so i mean that's a key part of the safe
drinking water act that we administer is
to make sure people are notified of
exposure so to the extent you have an
uncooperative entity um
yeah that is a concern i i don't tend to
find that to be frequent there are those
that out there that just think
all you know our science is just not
worth anything and therefore they're not
gonna tell anybody but that few and far
between
um but there could be that scenario and
i guess
the way i look at this is not walking
away from requiring notifications
sometime in the future it just gives you
a more complete picture within a year of
what's happening out there and then you
can decide the nature of future sampling
or notification requirements but
your concern
in very
rare circumstances could occur
representative kelly
yeah thank you mr chair oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry representative post
i didn't i didn't ever i didn't have a
written down
work session thank you i'm too lazy
thank you for yielding to me um
so earlier you talked about a um
the ability for people to go online and
see
um who was tested and things like that
you already had that and you said it's
open to the public to look at
we have the data available
a few different ways first this viewer
which is more like a general
neighborhood scale you can look for
results
then we issue for public water systems
we issue a legislative report twice a
year where we summarize the pfast
results for all public water systems
that have to test for pfas all 1200 of
them
and that's online
and then we have
our one-stop data files our waste sites
where any private well it's testing
around a given
active contamination site you can look
up the results it requires some work
going through reports and things like
that
we could
commit to
developing a report that summarizes this
sampling and
you know i would have to ask for senior
leadership but i don't see why health
and human services too in department of
ed because again we don't have
relationships with these schools in
daycare for the most part to make sure
that they don't have any problems with
putting a summary of results for those
entities online
seems like it would make sense to me but
i need to make sure those other agencies
aren't aware of some issues that i'm not
okay
and then just
as a as a thought i know
for our school district
board members alternately take turns
going in to check what is being paid out
so
if we're paying for a test to be done
i'm assuming more than just someone at
the school it would be a board member
that would look at that and approve that
payment out so i don't i don't think
there would be as much of a fear because
there is oversight it's not like it
would go to one single person it's
reviewed by several so
but if if it could be posted
i mean that way everybody could look it
up right
yes i think we
we could post it i just need to check
with our management and the other
agencies that have more direct control
over these entities to make sure they're
not aware of an issue i'm not
but we post this kind of data for the
child care facilities and schools that
have their own wells already and that
are big enough to be a regulated system
that data's already online so i don't
see why the smaller ones couldn't be
either
i'd like to get to this uh i've got
representative kelly
i'll let you follow up but then i i then
i want to get this taken care of
um
i i wanted to ask about the osmosis and
the carbon filter are those proven to
have
remediate
the pfas
yes um epa has studied a lot of the
major
treatment units that are sold out there
and then there's also a certification
process that's not quite
good enough for drds's standards they
don't certified at epa's original value
but our testing has shown carbon and
reverse osmosis works and we have that
data all over the state for both the
initial wells and merrimack and
litchfield that we had treatment systems
put in
we had the pre and post sample results
over time and now we have dozens of
larger water systems with carbon units
that can't really use reverse osmosis
because you waste three gallons for
every one gallon of water
with that process and it's it's very
effective of removing the contaminants
we regulate some of the newer pfas
compounds for which we have limited
toxicity data they're called smaller
chain
they're removed at first but over
several months you'll start seeing very
low levels of things like pfda coming in
pfbs breaking through
right now it looks like the toxic
profile of those isn't as significant as
pfoa and pfos but the science is still
emerging on those
representative kelly for a question
thank you mr chair my question was
mainly answered by representative post
question it was about it seems like the
the crux of many people
not wanting to delay for you know future
testing is that we
the the
notification of parents not being
mandatory
the and i was going to just ask if we if
there's if we're able to see that data
that you collect on those 150 smaller
entities in a concise format then if
there is a number you know 75 who don't
want to report the data out in 75 or
above the limit some crazy
reason that we would as a body be able
to
see the data and then and then report
out to our constituents i don't know if
that's something that's allowed but you
pretty much ask said it's going to be
hhs that needs to answer that yeah i
mean the data in our hands is available
to the public
it's a matter of what we put out on our
website and again i think we could put
the table out on the website i just need
to
be respectful of the other agencies that
actually licenses those institutions to
make sure they're not aware of something
but the data in our database could be
handed over to you or anybody on the
street and
they can do press releases mailing
whatever they want that happens every
day
okay i want to get this to get this
taken care of uh i'm gonna take uh this
is work session so uh you don't even
have we i'm just gonna take consensus
we have a bill
we have
a uh we we have a proposal
where are we going
how many how many would like to
take
would
please don't vote twice
how many would like to
uh
move forward on the bill and work on it
and then i'll post the second question
will be how many would like to move
forward on the proposal and work on it
how many would like to
to work on the bill
and
work on it
one
two
and one two
three
four
five
five six
five roughly
all right on the
that's on the bill on the proposal
how many would like to work on
it think people would like to work on
the proposal
what do we want
what do we want on the out of the
proposal
he's gonna you're just gonna do it
you're going to do it
you
you want us to write a letter or you
will write a letter
i think
you would like to
okay
represent perez
the only thing that i i we added is
um yes and you know the report is
available online but um i would like to
see that report available for the rural
areas where parents don't have access to
computers or they don't have access to
the information yes we we we're talking
about
the whole state we're not just talking
about the areas you know with with the
parents they have the flexibility to see
the reports on the computer so how how
are we going to handle that part because
like i said you know i i
you know i represent a town but you know
in in my time we have areas that rural
areas and and i know some other
representatives represent rural areas
how the parents going to have access if
they don't have internet or they don't
have a computer access
library right
all right
uh
i don't know how we answered that yeah
mr chairman certainly i'll be happy to
talk to represent perez about that
because i do have some concerns i mean
some of the data on the des website is
not up to date as well i know in
rochester all the schools have been
tested for lead yet only half of them
show us being cleared and some of them
are still showing high lead standards
and they're not but
my recommendation would be and if the
committee would agree to it is that we
send this an interim study he says he's
going to be getting stuff to us within
the next 12 months or so and if we could
uh hold this and in the fall if we
haven't gotten what we're looking for
then we move ahead with the we resubmit
the bill and if not
we we let the bill go if they've come up
with you know if they're making
substantial progress on this issue
because i think we all want to see
progress on this issue and we also want
to see some way that maybe
they may be able to come up with
something or maybe we have to have a
bill that that deals with just parental
notification
but it's it's something we can pick that
up at that time and so we send it to
interim study we can work on it in the
fall and uh take a look at what des has
available meet again and and then move
forward from that point and i would be i
would be happy with that
thank you very much i think
thank you really
i appreciate i appreciate your
your insight
uh i
think we're going i'm going go move now
into executive session
where we will
i mean i will entertain a motion uh
to uh for interim study
of this bill is is that is that
sufficient
all right i'm going to enter into
executive session don't don't go in here
mr kernan
uh because i'm going to be asking you
for some stuff
all right we're going to
enter executive session
on house bill
and do i have a motion
representative smith oh oh shoot i
didn't want to make the motion oh
motion of interim study as
i have a second
second by representative vale
is there
any more discussion i think
well let's uh
to speak on your motion
think we've said enough already okay
thank you
representative
vice chairman we'd be happy to hear that
i echo what's been said already i think
we've been very thorough and i'm glad
for the motion thank you
thank you and the chair appreciates
the
what the
maker of the motion has done he's made
he's made it he's made life's a lot
simpler for the committee
and i appreciate it because i think a
lot of
there is good things in this bill
but i think
you know it it probably its time will
come but not now but thank you very much
uh will the
clerk please call the roll
on a motion of interim study
representative harb yes
representative huff yes representative
golds
representative horgan yes representative
creighton yes representative dodge yes
the clerk votes yes representative
healey yes
representative mayville
representative post yes representative
smith
yes
representative weston yes representative
grassy yes
representative gottling yes
representative cohen
representative connors
representative bale yes
representative kelly yes
representative perez
yes
representative egan yes
and representative franzulov yes
unanimously passed
thank you consent consent yes yes for
consent
and uh
close the hearing on uh
or close i'll close the executive
session
uh and we're still in the just for a
second on the work session mr kern and
uh i guess we're gonna ask you to
you have some some work to do just to
get us uh
more of a
i'm going to copy the of what he
will flesh out the agreement
uh what you're
saying will you'll do and
[Music]
work on it from there and
please keep us informed
periodically of the progress and
because we will be watching it
so i appreciate your help
i think maybe i think we've come to a
good conclusion and thank you very much
for stepping up for it
thank you
with that i close the work session and
i think we can
say
that's it goodbye sayonara
hasta lavista sayonara uh
mr chair have you heard of any um bills
coming over from the senate yet any
bills i have not heard any i have not i
i'm not
they don't they don't tell me much
no i haven't ever
you